okay onion rings do we fix us are they
already out what's that spoon steam
table looks like it's river running
through here don't look the state of
this stove how old is that stone 33
years old Wow I mean I know the
restaurants called the old neighborhood
but the kitchens an old dilapidated
neighborhood yeah what's that
is that your Wow you are kidding me he
sticks it in the phone room he sticks it
back in there
what's that's right hand coding so it
doesn't stick a cans chosen yes Wow
my mother's definitely lost her high
standards over the last 15-20 years
granny I know she cares for this place
but the passion and the fire that I've
seen in her before is no longer there
[Applause]
damn it I probably burn them
son of a [ __ ] what is that horrible
little taste very watery taste like
final yeah excuse me is that if I
absolutely thank you wow that's dreadful
Tina Chef Ramsay's asking for you at 43
Tina's been such a hands-off manager for
so many years now that she's become so
blase yes I'm always that olive oil is
that canola oil no it was five hearts is
that the is that what you're serving
there it's that mix look at that
Jesus smells off smell what's in there I
don't know
there's nothing there cleaned I don't
know you're the front of house what a
mess
we bought from the abides yes to the
basic [ __ ] whoa what's that
tara misu oh my god now they've done
everyday probably a couple weeks ago
what is that a fake tree Massoud it's
that's a real toaster oh come on no this
so that's just sat there from fresh and
you said two weeks
no probably three weeks ago that is
longer than three weeks I'm sorry son
yes how long have these desserts beside
her a couple months I cook them double
mine kind of monsters for me three weeks
now I would say our mine was a couple
months do they stay out all night yes
that is a [ __ ] health hazard
oh gosh [ __ ] my boots the chefs will a
writer
[Music]
here's our stuff away the stuff for that
yes Oh excellent thank you you're
welcome
wow what a mess I asked for mid-rare but
somewhere you got to stick your knife in
it to to kill it I mean the thing still
[ __ ] movie
Sam I'm trying to cut into that I'll
some mid-rare but it's like well is that
steak frozen probably you just check
with the chef yes
was that fake frozen he wants to know I
don't was this frozen yeah yeah I don't
know if I should laugh or cry which one
next phenomenal so I'm sort of looking
forward to really nice classic piece of
meat
[Music]
we have flaming flaming on that I serve
tableside
people just love the chef's dream for
them in you hmm something simple
[Music]
greeting it from the tile yeah I'm gonna
finish it it's still cooking you'll love
this this salmon this is butter and
garlic
Oh Donny go sir and so the tsunami is
the garlic butter running down the
drainpipe right okay to be honest to it
thank you very much
quite welcome
[Music]
well that's the toughest most curious
Philip menial I've ever tasted in my
entire life
it means I'm chewy is assuming that me
so tough yeah no I finished Chef Ramsay
hated the food he hated the decor and I
can't understand why oh thank you
so steak yes oh yeah
my porterhouse New York
no rum there's only two cuts of steak
two steaks on the menu mistake house
should be minimum eight to ten how are
you welcome to PJ's my name is Colin
Farrell's like you how are you doing
great like for justice so I'll start
with crab cakes then maybe the shrimp
and roasted garlic ravioli and then I'll
have the filet mignon with the
gorgonzola demitasse alright I'll go put
this in for you Thank You Kelly no
problem I know Eric's a good chef so
what's to be nervous about
what are your crab cakes plus filet
mignon with gorgonzola medium rare and
it's probably right down I just love
what I do
this is perfect my food is good and if
he critiques it like I seen him critique
other people's food I'm gonna probably
throw it at him
what is that crab cake somebody spit on
my plate boys now that that's coulis
mangoes Oakley mango thank you is that
something a modern art museum splat look
Kelly Wow that's [ __ ] disgusting
is rancid plastic bits of crap moving
through the crab cakes so really okay oh
yeah chef send out a little surprise a
bits of plastic running through there
let's see the plastic I don't know where
it came from but it's deafening there
but I'm done with that
Thanks okay severe warning for what's to
come
Eric your sanity is a classic event
there's a strong
[Music]
[ __ ] him I have no idea where that place
to came from just happen to appear I
only would have placed away acacia the
onus out of the bar watching television
and they wondering why they're all doing
well is that Josie there the end yes all
the time
he'll sit there most of the night oh
yeah Joe does need to get off his ass
and start paying attention always my
food fantastic I'm able to leave you
alone to eat you know thank you
[Music]
how'd you like to stake me quite tough
now they always said with Rory Enzo yeah
no thank you my pleasure